okay we're here with doug berger doug
tell us a little bit about who you are
and what you do at microsoft
i'm a researcher in microsoft research
technologies division
the new division that was just formed so
i'm a processor architect by training
i was at the university of texas on the
faculty for 10 years before moving to
microsoft in 2008
where i built advanced processors and
new architectures
and how did you get into computing and
programming what was your first computer
well when i was seven eight nine ish i
my dad was a professor at smith college
and he brought home
a a crt monitor
and a modem where you plug the handset
into the
the foam pads and we could connect to
the the vacs at umass
university of massachusetts at amherst
and so we hooked up and i started
playing games and uh
you know colossal cave adventure and
then uh started writing programs
so tell me more about your team at msr
there's some work that you've done
around data centers and that's what we
want to focus
on today tell us about that work and and
what you've done
well the first thing i have to say is
that i'm almost embarrassed to be
interviewed about this work because so
much of
the innovation and the ideas and the
hard sweat was done by my team uh the
team is
it's one of the best teams in the
hardware business the the set of people
is absolutely amazing
they really are a ninja team and they
you know we all are on this
shared mission together uh so they work
really hard
they're brilliant they're much smarter
than i am uh
you know they're just they're a
phenomenal team and and
i know we're going to talk about a
little bit today but what they've pulled
off is amazing
it's really disruptive and it's a
testament to the team that they were
able to succeed
and how does that impact felt around
around the industry let's let's talk a
little bit about what
what you've worked on here um
what what is the impact that it's made
it's a
platform for accelerating data center
services
and so up until now data centers have
been
typically built with servers with
processors cpus and memory and network
and
flash and disks there haven't been a lot
of specialized accelerators put in
because you really want you really want
all of the servers in your data center
to be as similar as possible
and microsoft has moved in that
direction so that your services can run
across you know many servers as opposed
to being stuck in one corner
uh you know if you if that service grows
faster than you anticipate and
the the servers aren't the same you're
you're kind of stuck
or you might buy too many servers and so
what we've done
is created a programmable hardware
platform
based on fpgas and put it into a large
number of servers as a pilot
and showed that yes you can actually do
this you can put these hardware
accelerators in
and and accelerate many diverse services
with them
so let's start there what is an fpga for
someone who doesn't know
what's going to probably be a lot of
people so in fpga it stands for field
programmable gate array
and you can think of it as a as a chip
that can be
where the the hardware can be changed on
the fly in a few seconds typically
and the the core ideas rather than
burning in the circuits
as transistors with polygons you know if
you want to make say a a chain of and
gates
on a chip you know typically what you'll
do is you'll create a mask
and you use photolithography light to
etch down
you know some polygons on the chip that
form those and gates out of transistors
and it's a one-time index it's a
one-time endeavor you you burn it
and and it's there and it's never going
to change yeah what an fpga does is they
put a lot of little
little memory blocks on the chip that
are all networked together
and those memory bot those memory blocks
will hold a little bit of state
that allows you to put in some inputs
and the state says what's the logic
function in them
and then the outputs represent that
logic function okay so i i program the
ands and ors in that little table
by setting the bits in it appropriately
so that i get the right output
so it's programmable logic and for these
chips do you program them
for the data center or are they per
application so they're per application
what fpgas have traditionally been used
for is prototyping
asics or custom chips so you have a
design you do the design
you want to test it out in fpga first to
make sure it's right
before you go and spend millions of
dollars to have the chip manufactured
yeah and you know they run much faster
than software because they really are
you know they really are running in
hardware i mean the lookup tables are
slower than raw gates
but only about 10x you know software is
100 to 1000 x slower yeah to simulate a
chip
and so you can run very rapidly and then
fpgas as they've gotten larger and
larger they've been used in more and
more things
uh they're used heavily in networking
gear telecom gear network switches
but until now they haven't been widely
used in the data center and
what is the problem that you were trying
to solve with the data center is it a
speed
issue are you trying to speed things up
in the data center or what
uh what solution does this solve well
it's speed power and cost
so what we've seen over the past few
years is that the performance of
individual
microprocessors especially server
processors but also the clients as well
has started to cap off you know we don't
see clock rates
growing very much faster anymore uh the
chips aren't getting nearly as
energy efficient per transistor as they
used to this is all the challenges we
faced with silicon scaling
yeah and uh you know it's my belief and
and some of my colleagues share my view
that the number of cores that we're
starting to see you know the growth and
the rate of core counts is starting to
slow down too or
imminently we'll be slowing down so this
is the curve of moore's law
and you're saying that moore's law uh
may not be the constant that it had been
believed to be
and that uh it may plateau in the near
future
right so and what does that mean for
computing
well moore's law was defined by gordon
moore in a publication a really short
one of three or four pages in 1965
and he really talked about the number of
transistors per chip
was going to double every 18 months to
two years yeah and that really held true
for
50 years it's amazing a 50-year
exponential is a long time
yeah for doubling every you know within
it within a couple of years
um now there was something else called
dinard scaling that bob denard who was
the inventor of dram
uh defined in a paper in 1974 from ibm
and that he gave the rules for how you
shrink transistors
on a regular cadence yeah and denard
scaling
the way he specified it was such that
each time you shrink the transistors you
shrink the channel length
the gate oxide width the channel doping
concentration the doping atoms in there
the voltage all of it would be scaled
proportionally
and when you did that you'd get a
reduction in
power the transistor would go much
faster
and it would be much smaller so it was
like magic yeah and that ran for 40
years
dinard scaling failed uh around the mid
2000s 2005
because the the insulator on the
transistor started to get so thin
that you couldn't shrink it anymore
without lots of electrons flowing across
and leaking
yeah and so that that that's really why
we saw this
this big pivot from frequency scaling to
multi-core
and so now we've had these stresses and
this power crisis grow and grow
now we're starting to see real
challenges on moore's law itself
and you know the transistors used to get
cheaper because they'd be doubling for
the same
every generation for effectively the
same price yeah and we're now starting
to see that flatten out as well
yeah so sometime between now uh and i'd
say the next five years
we're going to hit an economic end to
moore's law and transistors are going to
stop getting cheaper
and at some point it won't be economic
to make smaller transistors
and then we'll see a hard stop and the
implications for the industry are really
really strong
and talk about the implications what
does that mean that
hardware just won't come down in price
like it had in the past well it
certainly won't come down as fast
but what it means is if you're if you're
a semiconductor manufacturer
and you've been offering a chip a
product that every generation you double
the number of transistors
which allows you to add a lot more
functionality and run the thing at the
same power
despite the doubling of transistors and
the extra functionality and sell it for
say a hundred dollars
now if you want to double the
transistors if the transistor cost is
flattened
you'll have to sell it for 200 yeah and
that really breaks the economics of a
lot of these businesses
and it will really change people's
business models uh and so
we will see we're already seeing that
pressure you know we're already seeing
the
the cost improvements flattened out and
so we're starting to see pricing
pressure
but that pressure hasn't gotten strong
enough to terminate the silicon scaling
yeah i mean once that terminates i think
if you're if you're a silicon
manufacturer you have to move to a
different business model for the most
part so uh talk about the impact that
the
fpga will have on uh moore's law is it
something that will extend this a little
bit it gives us a little bit of
breathing room in the meantime
i would say that that you know an fpga
can accelerate
uh software when you move something in
and if it's
an amenable workload by about 100x yeah
a6 you know typically a thousand x
in terms of performance per joule fpgas
are about 100x
and so i mean what that means is that if
we
are able to deploy this programmable
hardware in our cloud
we will be able to start moving
workloads over
yeah now i should emphasize here this is
still a research project
sure you know this is i think our goal
as researchers is to try to shift the
industry
but but when you have a lot of
programmable logic in your cloud
it's a target where you can start
migrating services over each time you do
you might get 10x 20x tune in some more
get 100x
and as you move more and more services
over you get more and more efficiency
so even if uh moore's law stops
or even if even if moore's law keeps
going but for cost reasons
our our cpus aren't getting that much
faster yeah okay
this gives us a scaling path yeah yeah
for some number of years we can keep
improving the performance of our
services
we can keep improving the quality of our
services running at larger scale
we can improve the efficiency of our
services the cost of our services
well past the end of moore's law yeah so
let's talk about uh
some of the collaboration you've had
with the bing team
so when we started this project back in
2000 early 2011 uh jim lehris and i and
jim since left microsoft
uh to take a prestigious position
elsewhere and andrew putnam who's on my
team now
and as our hardware guru got together
and we said let's
let's think about what we could do to
really change the you know change the
game for bing
give them a big jump in efficiency for
for a search
and so we met with bing leadership uh in
january of that year
and they said this looks really
interesting could be disruptive i mean
it's a little crazy uh but
you know programmable hardware in the
cloud yeah but it seems like uh
an interesting opportunity and if you
can get the efficiencies that are
possible it would be really great for
them yeah really great for us from
and so uh we started building a
prototype and i have to say bing
throughout this entire process has been
simply wonderful
i mean they've given us a lot of
consulting early on
you know giving sort of guiding us on
what would be feasible for them
design requirements they put in a lot of
time
later on they started partnering with us
you know being software engineers spent
a lot of time working through the
interfaces the apis
they hired an amazing guy named derek
chu uh
who is the lead hardware leads a
hardware team in bing
to support this effort and
and so they've really put a lot of skin
in the game
and been partners and i think uh sudoram
lanka who runs the index surf platform
team
uh has been simply amazing i mean he's a
brilliant engineer he's open-minded
he's willing to take risks but he's
conservative because he has to deliver
uh you know just the sort of person you
really want to have working at microsoft
and so the bing team throughout this has
been i think
conservative because they have to
deliver working solutions sure but
aggressive in that they're open-minded
and willing to try
try really interesting things and it's
just it's phenomenal to see
to see how you can balance that
aggressiveness and conservatism and
really try to jump out into a technology
leadership position
while ensuring that your stuff will work
at scale and what does catapult afford
the bing
development team that they couldn't do
before
well it really does two things so in the
ranking engine
we moved i would say a significant
portion of the compute heavy part
of page ranking which is uh for search
engines is
you know when you have a document or a
query and you want to
decide which documents you return in
what order you know your site you'll
take some subset of them that look like
the promising candidates
you'll rank them you'll sign them each a
score then you sort the order and that's
the
sort that list and that's the order in
which you return them and that is an
enormously computationally heavy task
i mean both both our competitors and
bing
do massive amounts of computation on
each page to figure out is it a good
response for this query
and so by moving most of that into fpgas
bing has shown that they're able to
run larger models potentially within the
time they have to score the documents
and they can also run higher throughput
so they can do this with more servers
so it saves bing money they can get
potentially better results it saves
energy
you know better for the environment yeah
you know at
we think affordable cost and what are
the next steps for catapult
so bing has uh worked with us on this
pilot
you know we we deploy we brought up
their ranking engine on our hardware
on a bet of 600 servers actually 1632
servers to be precise
so we had the hard hardware manufactured
we deployed it in that bed of servers
uh and then we worked this is all custom
hardware that you were working with well
we built custom hardware put it in our
servers so it was designed to be
compatible and fit in there cleanly yeah
we had a little tight spot in the back
to fit it these servers are very dense
and then we worked closely with bing to
bring up their
their software stack on these servers
offloading the part of ranking that we
had ported on the programmable hardware
yeah and so the results we report in the
paper are that we
just about double the throughput uh by
adding this accelerator
with the potential to run better models
so so right off the bat you can run with
half the number of servers
and we think there's a lot more gains to
be had so if someone wanted to get into
this area
working with uh fpgas what what language
do you typically use
and what are the the technologies behind
it that people should look into
so right now today uh much of the fpga
programming is done
with with uh things that are called hdls
for hardware description languages
these are vhdl or verilog and they're
they're basically concurrent programming
languages where
every function is being evaluated all
the time uh with regular synchronization
intervals
which are the clocks on the chip
determining okay now it's time to do the
next evaluation
so you can think of these as large
numbers of concurrent modules
uh with well-defined communication
interfaces fifos latches between them
yeah
and so every every cycle of the clock
you evaluate all of the logic so it's
very
it's very much a fine-grained parallel
programming language
and then increasingly because these
chips are getting more and more
pervasive
in many sectors people are writing
stacks now that will target
domain-specific languages or
you know or concurrent programming
languages more at the software level
that can be automatically translated
down to the hardware description
languages
that's great well i look forward to what
you have coming up next wonderful thank
you so much
thanks